prime minister netanyahu informed me
that israel has agreed to a mutual
unconditional cease fire to begin in
less than two hours
the egyptians have now informed us that
hamas
and the other groups in gaza have also
agreed the united states fully supports
israel's right to defend itself
against indiscriminate rocket attacks
from hamas
and other gaza-based terrorist groups i
assured him of my full support
to replenish israel's iron dome system
to ensure its defenses and security in
the future
let's bring in our panel to talk about
the latest remarks and developments on
the middle east matthew conetti founding
editor of the washington free beacon
mara liason national political
correspondent of national public
radio and trey gowdy former congressman
from south carolina welcome to all of
you
um trent want to start with you what do
you make of the president's remarks
today he's faced a lot of pressure from
the progressive
more leftist part of his party including
members on the hill who don't want him
to be so full-throated in his defense
of israel our ally in that region
yeah certainly a repudiation of that
wing of the party there
there's a you know bernie sanders aoc
and others are having a really difficult
time telling the
terrorists from our allies this is a
repudiation of that wing of the party
i'm i'm glad he talked to netanyahu i
hope he's also going to send a message
to hamas
and to iran what's even better than a
ceasefire shannon
is not to need a ceasefire so tell them
to stop firing rockets into israel
and then we won't need the ceasefire
well the president also said that they
will work on a number of things getting
humanitarian
humanitarian aid in as quickly as
possible in rebuilding gaza which has
obviously had a lot of destruction in
the last 11 days or so
but he also talked about the fact that
they want to work with the palestinian
authority
not hamas mara it sounds like he's
trying to be very clear
about exactly who's at fault here and
who we intend to work with moving
forward
yeah i think the president's statement
was pretty clear i think it really
undermines the republican talking points
that somehow he's controlled by the left
wing of his party or he does too much to
cater to them
this is pretty clear he wants to work
with the palestinian authority not hamas
he's going to help
israel replenish iron dome its defense
system that seems to have worked pretty
well against hamas rockets
uh so he knows where he stands in the
middle east i mean he did work for the
ceasefire
people criticized him for not coming out
and calling for a ceasefire
sooner even when about half the
democrats in the senate were calling for
one
but it was pretty clear that joe biden
like other american presidents before
him
did not want to call for a ceasefire
before israel was ready
to engage in one because they didn't
want to be left looking like they had
no leverage at all with the israeli
government
but i think you know we now know where
the president is i'm sure the
progressive wing of his party isn't
thrilled about it but i don't think it's
the kind of rift that's going to spill
over into other domestic issues
well they uh have talked about uh the
squad members in particular we think
about them but they're calling for
um this the stopping of weaponry and
funding uh
to israel the president was very clear
as mara mentioned about replenishing the
iron dome and how critical that has been
to protecting the people of israel
matthew i want to play something from
two different sides of the aisle
in the senate about how this is being
viewed on capitol hill and beyond
i believe that we should be mourning the
loss of israeli life
but we should also be mourning the loss
of palestinian lives
or perhaps some people think that
palestinian lives
don't matter i would hope not
i think it is shameful that the radical
left in the democratic party
uh is choosing this moment to try to
undermine
our friend and ally the nation of israel
and to to support hamas
the two are not morally equivalent
matthew it feels like so many the
conversations and disputes that are
happening on capitol hill and more
broadly in washington come back to these
sort of semantics games
about what people really mean what their
intentions are what do you make about
how this particular issue is playing on
capitol hill
i think someone needs to explain to
senator sanders that it was hamas who
initiated the violence by firing rockets
indiscriminately
at israel's civilian population it's
hamas that controls gaza
undemocratically since it
seized control in 2007 from fatah it's
rival palestinian faction
it's hamas that embeds its terror
infrastructure
within its own civilian population in
order to maximize
civilian casualties of its own people
and its hamas that in your own clip with
trey yingst
was firing on humanitarian aid we need
to be absolutely clear shannon it's
hamas's conflict and the reason that the
ceasefire is good news
is that it signals that israel is
confident it's destroyed enough of
hamas's terror infrastructure
to at least stop the rocket attacks for
some some amount of time
yeah the prime minister and defense
minister there in israel very clear that
that
was the goal and they would continue
until they felt they had made
that significant accomplishment to a
much less heated battle but one that is
political and growing here domestically
is this fight on capitol hill over
speaker nancy pelosi
in light of the cdc's conversation and
recommendations in recent days
mandating that masks still be worn on
the house floor when members are there
to
speak here is a bit of the back and
forth from the two sides over that
what the uh attending physician and
that's the guidance we have to go by
uh said unless people are
vaccinated we have to continue to wear
masks
uh in our meetings and on on the floor
we're required to wear a mask
on the house floor and in the committee
hearings ironically that's where the tv
cameras are so this is purely theater
apparently kovit works differently in
both chambers
because in the senate you don't wear a
mask in the house you have to wear a
mask
the only difference is the speaker she
doesn't want to abide by the cdc rules
she actually wants to have greater
control
trey i suspect this is one of those
things that makes you not miss
being on capitol hill in the house
one of a trillion shannon there were a
lot of rules when i was in the house and
they were usually honored only in their
breach
we weren't supposed to bring drinks on
the house floor we weren't supposed to
take pictures
almost everyone violated those i did not
i'm a rule follower which
which kind of brings me to my larger
point anyone can follow a rule they
agree
they agree with i mean it takes no
courage to follow a rule you agree with
it's those that we don't agree with that
separates the law and order people from
everyone else so if you don't like the
rule
then retake the house and change the
rules or
honor it or if you're gonna break it and
engage in civil disobedience pay your
dadgum fine
those are your three options honor the
rule change the rule
or engage in civil disobedience but pay
your fine if you're going to do so
i'm glad i'm not the only one still
using the phrase dadgum uh it was used
very nicely there dre
matthew what about this um you know
people who are saying i'll pay the fine
i'll do whatever well what about this
accusation from members that it's only
within tv
camera range that the masks are mandated
it's obvious that this is political on
pelosi's part she wants to punish the
members mainly republicans who haven't
taken the vaccine when in fact they're
only
endangering themselves by not taking the
by not having the vaccination
it's very politicized and partisan and
it only proves to me shannon that
there's no cure
for nancy pelosi's silliness
all right mara give us the final word on
this
final word is the cdc says if you're
fully vaccinated you don't have to wear
a mask inside or out
all right we'll leave it there panel
thank you so much when we come back
we'll hear from you on tomorrow's
headlines hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else